[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
odessa ville d'art et d'histoire
se barricade et protège ses symboles ce
sont des taches lumineuses sur des
photos satellites au moins quatorze
navires de la marine russe qui approche
à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
d'odessa sur la mer noire la statue du
duc de richelieu l'un des fondateurs de
la ville filmée ici avant la guerre est
aujourd'hui recouverte d'un tas de sacs
de sable au moment où il y avait eu
l'annexion d'un crime et vladimir
poutine avait essayé de froment t de
fomenter pardon des émeutes des émeutes
pro-russe pour montrer que déjà été
russe c'est à dire très mal terminée
l'opération ukraine se développent avec
succès dans le strict respect des plans
prix on trouvera d'ailleurs on a mis un
star wars nous n'avions pas d'autre
choix que la légitime défense pour la
sécurité de la gressier et donc de la
réalisation de l'opération militaire
spéciale puisque les pro russe avait
fini refermer dans une haie dans une
église qui avait pris feu et venir
poutine a accusé les ukrainiens d'avoir
d'avoir tué tué des russes et avait dit
je vengerait je les vendrais je voudrais
odessa président ukrainien ovationné par
le congrès américain a clamé cher
américain
vous avez une grande histoire et je
pense que vous avez traversé des
périodes qui vous permet de comprendre
de crin de nous comprendre maintenant
un moment où nous avons besoin de vous
toute confrontation directe avec la
russie aujourd'hui signifierait une
guerre nucléaire
jeanine ce qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de
demander l'intermédiation de la guerre
il sait parfaitement que les ni les
européens ni les américains ne peuvent
passer à ça effectivement ça va monter
pendant 10-15 jours probablement jusqu'à
la fin mars on devrait pouvoir atteindre
fanton risque d'atteindre 120 150 mille
contamination par jour devant la
préfecture de nice
environ 200 ukrainien qui attendent de
trouver une solution des papiers un
logement depuis quelques jours 500 à 800
réfugiés arrivent quotidiennement dans
le département des alpes-maritimes la
charge hospitalière c'est à dire
l'impact sanitaire de ce rebond
épidémique parce qu'il touche surtout
les jeunes parce que c'est invariant qui
est moins dangereux que les autres sera
contenu on a un président qui
visiblement aux abois aux abois et
qu'ils cèdent à la violence avec le
président simeone et voir ce que
donnerait ce que donnerait l'autonomie
peut-être qu'on ne se mettra pas
d'accord après une de malherbe est il
est possible qu'on ne se mettent pas
d'accord mais nous ouvrons nous ouvrons
ce dialogue si on doit parler d'autres
nuits alors on en parle et on en parle
sérieusement avec en disant qu'à
l'article de la constitution
on veut appliquer
comme ça ça veut dire ça nous donne
autonomie comme sa mêlée qui lui pour
donner l'autonomie est encore dépenses
sans qu'il y est pourquoi pas en 2018 m
il va en corse il oppose une fin de non
recevoir
avec un ton méprisant comme rarement un
président de la république l'a utilisé à
l'égard d'un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens il est prêt à tout et même à
dépecer la nation française en vérité ce
gouvernement est incapable de se faire
respecter d'assurer son autorité le
grand risque l'a7 les gens pensent que
ce soit fait les françaises et les
français mais même les soutiens ce que
leur dire s'il pense que c'est fait
c'est qu'on a perdu je ne sais pas si je
serai coeur kabila ce soir parce que
cette élection n'a plus aucun sens
gens là ça y est il y avait peut-être en
train de craquer et nous on se dit que
ben on va rester et puis si on peut
faire si on va faire scier non lâche pas
le truc depuis deux jours il flotte même
comme un air de sahara sur les sommets
français si les pyrénées
le sirocco qui a recouvert la france et
l'espagne et regardez là même atteint
jusqu'à nos massifs montagneux